[MUSIC]
Artificial Intelligence is everywhere.
Every company is taking advantage of it,
or needs to take advantage of it.
We at Stanford are thinking about
that across the university,
both the business point of view, but
also, actually the societal point of view.
[MUSIC]
>> To a lot of people, AI is just magic.
Through this program,
they can have a little bit of a better
understanding of what's actually entailed.
>> Honestly,
it was fear that drove me here [LAUGH].
I mean, everywhere you just keep on
hearing about AI, and what are you doing.
I'm a non technical person,
I want to makes sure that
I'm on the forefront to Fit.
>> Data per se is very valuable.
However, if you don't apply it and
you don't put it in the right algorithms,
you also not get much value out of it.
>> Each day starts with an overview
provided by a world class faculty member,
who's an expert in their field.
No equations, nothing complicated
going on, just high level insights.
And then, later on,
we take a either a deeper dive, or
we have someone from industry talk
about some of the issues in translating
some of the ongoing research in artificial
intelligence, and to business impact.
>> To better understand,
what's the [INAUDIBLE] regulatory
ethical framework around it.
Yeah, I thought, on the other hand, what
can we do in order to improve customer
experience or create additional revenues.
So combining those two perspectives,
I think it's a great value of the program.
>> What's really great about this program
is we're drawing from all of campus.
We have some great people coming
in from the engineering school,
the business school.
And we've also brought in someone from the
medical school to bring that perspective,
as well as the law school.
[MUSIC]
If you're going to learn about AI,
you want to do it here in Silicon Valley.
This is where everything is happening.
>> We're within a few miles of many of
the companies that are implementing AI,
as part of their core business strategy.
>> Whether I'm an engineer, whether I'm
in finance, whether I'm in public sector,
doesn't matter.
Things are changing fast.
What do we need to do?
>> There's just really
no place like Stanford,
in terms of bringing all of this
expertise together in one place.
>> I saw this program, and
it's a brilliant way to get introduced.
And there's that personal touch.
And there's this one week
of intensive learning.
So I mean, this environment,
you can't beat it.
[MUSIC]